what's going on guys
spoiler alert that's right we're gonna
be talking about spoilers today what
constitutes a spoiler and what are the
ethics of spoilers we are going to break
it down and we have a panel who cares
about spoilers first he is one of the
stars of Sullivan & Son on TBS Tuesdays
10/9 central
what's that when is it Mountain time
it's whatever the people that live in
the mountains
watch Steve burn Steve burn thank you
for being here um he is the head badass
at badass digest and he grows a mean
beer Devin Faraci high elf and he is the
director and editor of screen junkies
the editor of honest trailers oh my good
friend Dan Merle I still have to be here
yep let's open it up to everybody what
constitutes a spoiler what what's the
definition of a spoiler I don't even
know anymore I get people yelling at me
about spoilers for things that I'm like
well that's just the premise of the
movie so I don't yeah or a little bit
like in lone survivor we know there's
gonna be one survivor that way yeah we
live in an age where now we're all these
great comic books that you grew up
reading are now coming to fruition and
they look fantastic so because we have
the access to all this information on a
daily basis and you go to the same maybe
seven or eight websites a day you're
tracking your film that's coming out and
so there's almost like this
responsibility you have with yourself
where it's like how much information do
I want or not want when I go see the
film we're living in like a spoiler
culture we're like I think especially
since we have Netflix I'm gonna watch it
on my own time but until I do don't
spoil it for me and so it's like now you
have to constantly be aware because it's
like somebody's like hey I just started
watching Breaking Bad last week don't
spoil it for me it's like yeah that's
your own problem and yeah that that
drives me crazy once upon a time TV
especially it was like a it was an
appointment thing if you wanted to watch
your show on Monday you want [ __ ] Monday
you came to work on Tuesday but now it's
just right this thing where it's like
you know well I haven't seen I have
seven of them on my DVR don't tweet
about it well how you ask what
constitutes a spoiler like like Andy
Andy our boss he even says that like and
I somewhat agree like even if you just
go on Facebook the night the game of
Thrones is on and just like like oMG
Game of Thrones
he says that's a spoiler because they
you can't watch the show without
expecting I think that's kind of a gray
area you know what that really keyed in
like what what you said about an
innocuous tweet saying oMG Game of
Thrones like I knew something was coming
and then a really vague tweet kind of
did the math in my head for me like I
knew that a major person was going to
die don't go on Twitter man like I know
you're gonna watch Game of Thrones in
three hours because you're on the west
coast just don't go on Twitter for three
hours but even it but that's your choice
that you made the decision so I think
for me that's the other part that drives
me crazy is people like you know don't
tweet about like turn off the goddamn
Twitter I guarantee your job or your
life does not depend on Twitter being on
today what are the hours well what if
I'm not only spoiler phobic but I'm
addicted to social media I have you were
screwed my oh my god Steve what do you
think like just a if I tweeted oMG
Breaking Bad first of all is it a
problem that I'm using oMG that's a huge
problem
okay secondly um OMG Breaking Bad just
that I'm just saying Wow
Breaking Bad is mind-blowing oh I don't
know what the harm in that is it's just
you know it's just you see well there's
something you didn't give anything away
there's no spoilers there have you guys
ever harshly admonished someone about
spoilers I just I just did I'm gonna get
yelled at for saying it again okay so I
kind of got into a fight with a friend
of mine on Twitter about it which is
that another journalist spoiled the end
of the Avengers 2 and I just feel like
it was not necessary for like you know I
think a lot of people sort of who do
what we do for a living know what's
happening in Avengers 2 but that doesn't
mean you have to spread it around so
much right and especially this
particular ending beat I thought was one
that'd be very nice for able to discover
so it's kind of a bummer when I leave
right now because I don't want to know
but can I say as somebody who's you know
I'm not in the field that you guys are
what is the upside is it's just getting
traffic to the to your particular site I
don't understand the upside and it
almost ruining a film that is so
anticipated for so many people I don't
understand why you would want to do that
it's like you have a responsibility 95%
of kids want to want to go downstairs at
Christmas
and and ripen all their gifts there's
always going to be that 5% of kids that
sneaks out on Christmas Eve and opens up
and looks at all their gifts and if
you're the person that's giving them
that information yes you are going to
get that traffic but I suspect that
these are the people on the internet
that yell at you about spoiling things
yeah I suspect that they're the same
people that spoil things and turn that
post hypocrites though a lot of them not
so I think that's the thing about
spoilers is that on you know it's your
responsibility to not go on Twitter you
know a spoiler isn't that big a deal but
don't be a dick about it don't that's
the key it's just a basic human
etiquette of like just don't be a dick
common human decency yeah it's just
spoiling somebody else's good time just
so you can right get some kind of it I
don't know cheap thrill the worst people
so we broke down a lot of stuff now we
want to create the ultimate spoiler Bill
of Rights statute of limitations on
spoilers what constitutes a spoiler
let's start with movies how long after a
movie comes out can we start talking
freely about what happened and I think
if we're gonna be really good like not
until home video but I think
realistically it's like two weeks like
if you really gave them much if you
should go see it I think it's if it's
any marquee like summer tentpole movie
like a Star Wars or Avengers you get two
weeks if it's like sucker punch it's
like I'm gonna tell you other sense you
don't go that's true
I would spoil transformers for everyone
in the world if that meant oh I'll spoil
her right now buy Chinese products
basically yeah uh.well TV it's 24 hours
24 hour you can about Game of Thrones
yeah we will be watching Game of Thrones
within 24 hours of its airing there
might be extenuating they're always
going to be somebody who's like has an
extenuating circumstance like I was in
the hospital my mom died like tough like
you still have 24 it's an hour long it's
like you needed minor doctor yeah -
you're cruel yeah really on it you know
what my god you have like a know Devin
Stefan's a nice guy as that no dicks on
a ban your IP address yeah but if it's
TV go yourself I just think that 24
hours is I think TV is inherently a
social medium for 90% of the population
I think like a day or two is enough to
catch up on a show if you care enough
about the show to be up
I got spoiled so it's the rule of two
you get two weeks with a movie you get
two days with it I like that fits nice
it's nice ring to it
spoiler george RR martin no mercy okay
so that's a rule
don't be a dick i think we can all agree
a sugar one rule okay also don't take it
personally because there will be people
who no matter what you do we did a
supercut it was called the spoiler alert
ha ha ha
I had a spoiler alert at the beginning
we still got comments saying do you want
15 movies for me like this so that's I
think that's also like don't there it
doesn't matter what you do you don't
have to take out a vendetta against
somebody for spoiling something life
will go on life will go on yeah there's
another movie right around the bed
that's gonna get ruined for you yeah
life wife will go on unlike unlike for
Ned Stark who was brutally decapitated
in episode 8 of the first season of Game
of Thrones guys I think we came up with
our spoiler Bill of Rights number one
don't be a dick take other people into
consideration for once in your life
number two stay off of Twitter number
three the rule of two's two weeks for a
movie
two days for a TV show number three rule
of two's that's copy is it simply hahaha
yes and number four don't take it
personally things will get spoiled life
goes on guys I think we did a real
service for Humanity today what did you
think of our spoiler bill of rights are
there any amendments that you'd like to
add leave us an answer in the comment
section below tell us what you think
about it best answer we're gonna send
you a screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank my awesome panel Steve Byrne check
them out and Sullivan & Son TV s
Tuesdays 10:00 9:00 central not sure
what Mountain Time is the concept of it
I'm not sure what
it is Devin Faraci badass digest Dan
Merle screen junkies honest trailers I'm
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter thanks
for watching bye bye you're not a bad
actor he's done other stuff in your life
good but for some reason in this movie
he is always off every line he says is
off plan on murdering me in my sleep
what No